[Musique]
jean michel vous c'est vous maintenant
greg il y autant vous à pied j'ai gagné
autant qu'on aime énormément kpg
isabelle morini bosc qui a piégé
benjamin castaldi
il a plaidé également jean michel maire
regardez c'est parti ça lui sait gré
guillotin nous avons décidé de figer une
partie des chroniqueurs ne touche pas à
mon poste pour ça nous avons fait appel
à la complicité de cyril hanouna
il a ainsi dit aux chroniqueurs qu'il
fallait qu'il rencontrera youtuber
talentueux sur quitté pmp a décidé de
s'appuyer la saison prochaine pour être
davantage présents sur le web c'est
youtuber c'est moi et je vais camper un
mec insupportable aux foulards énorme je
vais piger les chroniqueurs avec la
complicité de lionel le bras droit de
cyril hanouna et de david mon associé
aujourd'hui jean michel mr première
partie ça va ça va être tu connais bien
les différents jeux on s'était croisé il
ya 80 ans je faisais l'oiseau twitter
qu'on peut dire oh là là l'oiseau
d'arrêter de se droguer jusqu'au 20 on
n'a pas des messages twitter merci
oiseaux depuis j'ai pris un peu de
gagner si rim le contact et il me dit
voilà on a besoin de toi pour driver un
peu les chroniqueurs on essaie de
redorer un peu l'image ternie par tous
ces scandales
donc je dis ok tu me donnes un gros
dossier c'est pour ça que j'ai dit va
voir un maître losail en face mois après
tu vas cyril il m'a dit tu vois on a un
budget qui est cinq cas par mois
tu vois pour venir coacher les
chroniqueurs moins 5000 par un quiz
après là on a parlé de lui proposer de
quoi ils mettaient pmp mais cyril
guillotin qui présente une émission sans
que je me dis que j'aurais peut-être
moyen que je vais mettre mes fans et que
lui il m'amène ses fans en télé donc
après un petit peu plus que moi je me
fais embêter tous les jours pendant que
tu as parlé fac et henin qui demande
elle est une ode aux terrasses qui donne
des trucs pour des bonnets monroe ou
c'est pas des fans d'un cinéma qui
demandent de l'argent
ok je vais continuer presque du coup on
va perdre le fil entre tout ce que vous
êtes les chroniqueurs pour moi il ya
deux poids deux mesures tout à l'heure
j'ai rendez vous avec cast appareils en
plus il est salida il est en pleine
dégringolade mais je me dis si juge est
une bouée qui l'attrapent je peux
peut-être le ramener à quai il est loin
du quai on peut encore le sauvait faire
quelque chose avec lui il sera en effet
trois contes toi t'es pas dans le groupe
de caste à nankin au fond de l'eau mais
t'es pas celui qui me posent le moins de
soucis à proprement parler parce que
c'est tout ce que tu évoques toutes les
casseroles que tu traînes au cuvier
whaou ok là tu as passé de 3 ans qui
n'ont pas été faciles
moi je poste un truc sur ma fan bei je
leur dit jean michel maire pour nous
c'est quoi ça va être c'est un vieux
vicelard serre que demain moi je vais à
l'opéra très clairement c'est un endroit
a dit mme claes
il amène pas mr avec moi demain je vais
voir les tuche public de beauf
là je me dis ok mer j'y vais y aller tu
joues mal je sais que tu es vachement
bien plus bas à bojan qui qu'elle ne put
le cinéma populaire indien genre ci
dessus c'est les gens qui n 9 heures moi
je pense oui parce que je sais même mal
vu que c'est pas de rentrer dans un
concours de taille de bil toki moi je
n'ai pas traité de coeur en plus je
t'aime bien à la base tu travailles tu
faisais l'oiseau twitter et tous que
j'étais encore tout en bas tout le temps
aujourd'hui je passe des castings j'ai
peut-être faire partie de la vérité si
je mens le
nouveau là le pré le prequel quand tu
dis tu joues d'or ça fait un moment
qu'on tue pas le derrière en arrière
plan avec un plateau de fruits de mer
comme ça en gros moi j'ai juste dit à
sir est un truc je ne je ne m'associerai
pas à jean michel maire en même temps ça
se saisir les deux sous les deux parties
sont d'accord je t'ai pas nourri là
dessus j'ai eu du mal c'est bon je
t'explique en gros il ya trois niveaux
pour l'excellent niveau 1
ça c'est les indécrottables d'accord le
type nabila de leurs maux c'est ce jeu
pas moins niveau 2 c'est les
indésirables et j'ai un chat je suis là
dedans mais là effectivement je fais
partie selon c'est en gros ceux avec qui
je suis prêt que je prédis avec les
shows pas m'associer est en fait partie
et niveau 3 talent est sauvable en gros
c'est ce que je suis prêt à aider via
paris m'associer avec eux publiquement
pour les pousser toi tu es encore trop
sale pour ça oui tout est sur la table
donc le but c'est que déjà tu arrêtes de
nous parler de ta pub mal on t'arrête
vraiment à chaque fois que j'allume la
télé je me dis il va nous parler de
cette oeuvre
c'est complexe est ce que ça apporte une
valeur ajoutée de parler de sa top toute
l'émission
bah je sais pas quand tu as une petite
étoile tient du grand écart est mis à
toi tu as beau avoir des 2 millions tous
les jours si c'est pour qu'elle a fait
en dix mois
or le boulet mais moi je rentrais du cas
chinois china qui me s'ouvre à cayenne
et sérieux moi ma famille mais c'est pas
possible tu es indécrottable vraiment
bon coup je vais te faire redescendre en
niveau 1
tu oses une armée rouge jaune ans parce
que si tu es niveau as à dire qu'on
trouve à plus de synthés bio n'est pas
nouvelle bombe alors donnez moi je vois
tu as fait le figaro parle mais
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'il fait et
parle de sa tabac à télé et il met son
pif dans les seins d'une meuf comme ça
on dirait faudrait que je fasse un petit
stage dans moto dans le monde
excuse moi j'ai mal à écouler tendinite
avant de demander
bon mais que les gens se disent jong
mère et une amie guéri de la tob
vis-à-vis du public
là c'est important pour moi et pour ça
j'ai envie qu'on est un dispositif 360
et retrouver demain la deuxième partie
de l'épisode pour découvrir ma solution
pour guérir jean-michel de la table que
ce temps la pensée tôt ce site entre
gervais en tce
[Applaudissements]